hey guys it's benefits of a G from G
tracker here and today's video is going
to be about uh just how to merch in
general um as a beginner um I've seen a
lot of you guys come in recently to the
Discord chat and ask what type of items
you should be flipping or where you
should be looking for items uh what type
of margins would be good to look at um
and I really want to go into the basics
in this video on you know where to start
you know what you should be looking for
in terms of margins in terms of trading
volume um because there is some red
flags that you should be paying
attention to uh but if you're a merchant
that's been doing this for a while
you've already been flipping for quite
some time uh this video isn't really for
you this is going to be more for people
who have never flipped before like
whatsoever um but before we get into
this video uh why don't we go over to
our last video
where we did a Christmas special
giveaway where we were going to award
two winners a month-long subscription to
our website so why don't I go over to
that real quick and see who our winners
are all right guys so just like last
time uh this is a tool that I used to
pick out a random winner from our first
video where we did a two Bond giveaway
um so I've already uploaded the link
here and this is going to let me know if
someone tried commenting more than once
and trying to boost their chances of
winning and if they if I see a user who
has commented more than once I'm going
to have to go back to see if they
entered their GE tracker username more
than once um because if they did then
I'd have to disqualify them because
that's you know that's cheating and it
wouldn't be fair for everyone else that
only commented once um which is the fair
way to do it so I already uploaded the
URL here so let's go ahead and load the
video okay and then we're going to be
able to pick a random winner which there
69 unique people who have commented on
this so I guess one person commented
more than once so let's see
here okay so to giggy gamer
atlic your site is amazing mate made far
more flipping that I've made doing
anything else well cheers um so good
luck or congratulations lift hope uh
toky gamer live.com you've just won
yourself a month-long subscription to
our website seeing here that you've only
made one comment and then we're going to
go ahead and pick our second
winner Emily host only commented once
awesome videos and nice tool I'd love to
win a bond so I can start flipping some
more member member items G tracker name
mil
6255 well thank you for the nice
compliments guys um so congratulations
mil and the other guy for winning a
month-long subscription to our website
and in terms of the Bond um sad to say
that this wasn't the video that we were
doing a bond giveaway but Emil if you're
watching this video then um be sure to
stay tuned for the video in which we're
going to do our 11 old school RuneScape
Bond giveaway um but that's not going to
be something um well I I'll actually
talk more about that later on so
congratulations guys and thank you so
much for the kind comments and let's get
back into the
video all right guys so uh usually the
first thing that people ask is you know
which item they should start flipping
and you know I can't I can see how
that's a difficult question to answer
seeing how um when you type when you go
into the grand exchange you have to type
in an item yourself and you really don't
know um what type of item to flip I mean
there's so many variety of items that
you could possibly go into and you don't
really know um where they even stand
unless you click on the item um so
luckily for a beginner type merchants we
have our high volumes tool and you know
this is really um perfect for those who
are really really new to flipping in
general um generally these have uh the
lowest risk possible usually high volume
items have very very low risk uh but one
thing to keep in mind um when you're
looking at this tool here and I'm just
going to be clicking on this every now
and then so I don't log out um when
you're looking at this tool here when
you click on this tab here to show the
highest profit to the lowest profit
you're going to notice some items have
some really high margins and right now
um this is a stamina potion uh but right
off the bat I always tell people to look
at the trading quantity and right now
we're going to see that the buy sell
ratio is negative so that's indicating
that there's more people selling this
than there is buying it so right now in
my head I already know that this right
here is probably not going to be the
type of margin that I'm going to find in
game right now and it's probably going
to be closed down pretty fast um seeing
how there's more people trying to get
this off their inventory as opposed to
people trying to buy it um I can see the
margin on this closing in rather quickly
so why don't we go ahead and check real
quickly to see um what the margin really
is so right now we're seeing that the
current price is about 6K
6.7k and then the um the approximate
sell price is around 7K uh um and I'm
going to go ahead and click on this
right now so we can load the graph for
that but quickly why don't we go to the
S potion which was a four do and then
when you are um when you are new to
flipping and you're using the high
volumes tool you're going to always want
to check the margins in game regardless
you know this High margins tool right
here uh that we had that I was showing
earlier is really to give you an idea of
items that you could flip that are
showing a profitable margin at any given
point in time but as I was showing you
right now the stamina potion had a
significant amount of people selling
this as opposed to buying it so right
off the bat I already know that that
margin has gone down and to check the
margin in game all you do is just put
the price in as a as a ridiculously high
price so you instantly buy it and then
you take the item and you instantly sell
it for a really low
price and then all you're going to do is
is go to your GE history and it's going
to show you what the margin actually was
and right off the bat we can see that
the margin isn't the 300 and something
that it was showing earlier and it's
really closed down rather quickly and
you know this is something that I've
seen you guys talk about in Discord chat
you guys have been looking at the high
volumes tool you've been saying hey it's
showing that there's a 400 GP margin but
when I go in game you know it's only
like 20 GP margin you know and that was
was because when we look at the trading
quantity people are trying to get it off
their hands no one is buying this and
you know I always say basic economics
says that you know supply and demand
supply and demand um since there's more
people trying to get rid of this the
price is going to go down and the margin
is going to collapse on itself pretty
quickly so when you see an approximate
profit right here something like this
and then you go in game saying hey this
isn't right you always want to look at
all the data okay I always see people
people looking at specific pieces of
information and then thinking you know
this is always the way it should be and
I always tell them you know that's not
right you should always be looking at
everything always look at the whole
picture um so right off the bat we
already know that there's a ton more
people trying to sell this as opposed to
buying it and then if we go down here we
can see on the monthly timeline that
generally this was on a decline so this
this was something that was bound to
have margins collapse on itself um
seeing how the demand isn't really there
and then these are just abnormalities
here so this might have caused that huge
uh margin Spike right here so if I saw
this and I saw this I already know that
you know people are trying to get this
off their hands that there's really no
buyers so because there's more suppliers
then there's the demand for it price has
gone down just like the graphs have been
showing you and then when I click on the
weekly price it's going to show me that
there was this one abnormality here
where there was a price point where some
guy got lucky and was able to sell it
for a ridiculously high price than it
normally would be sold at so that's
something to keep in mind so that
obviously scooted the little approximate
profit here and you know just digging a
little bit into this is going to show
you a clear picture as to what's r
really going on and we're going to see
that this is really selling you know not
for that much of a margin at most times
um not the 396 that it was showing but
you will see on occasion that people are
having some weird abnormalities like
this and this isn't something that you
should Bank on you shouldn't buy um you
know like 10,000 of these and try and
think okay I'll try and put the item in
for 9,000 in the grand exchange hoping
someone will buy it maybe you'll get one
Buy offer off that but showing the
monthly graph here uh the month the
long-term trend is going down so you're
not going to see that 9k price that you
were seeing on the day or weekly time
graph um but why don't we go back here
and look at another item to see an
example um just going to click on this
okay and then right now it's showing me
G crimey irit leaf and then if you look
at the buying selling quantity there's a
whole lot more people buying this as
opposed to selling it at this point in
time there's about 111 GP margin so this
is telling me right off the bat this is
in demand at this current point in time
and this can obviously change any point
in
time so why don't we click on this to
see a clearer picture Okay so there's
buy and selling quantity is in favor of
the buyers or the sellers trying to make
a profit off of this now if you look at
the monthly timeline it's pretty erratic
um so this might be this is a perfect
perfect example of something that um
someone who is more used to flipping uh
would try and make a long-term
investment in so if you see these kind
ofre umre uh if you see these kind of
bumps like this then you might want to
invest at a very low price you know
stocking up on this and hoping that
maybe it'll get a higher price on this
um but that's generally for people who
are more experienced doing this and if
we look at a longer time frame we're
going to see that you know it still
plays that weird
fluctuation um throughout uh the entire
year and if we click on the weekly time
frame it's still kind of erratic we can
see that there's a huge drop big big
increases big drops um so that's what's
playing with around with the price right
now and if we look down here we're going
to see the overall High overall low so
there's a generally big profit margin
um if we look down at the trading volume
there's a pretty significant amount of
this being circulated and generally
there's more buyers than there is
sellers during this during today um
let's click on the weekly time frame it
still looks like there's a lot more
buyers let's click on the monthly time
frame okay so now that we look at the
monthly time frame now it's starting to
look like there's more sellers than
there is buyers but since that uh since
we're looking at a shorter time frame
and this is for beginners um I won't go
too much into that so um right off the
bat I already know that there is a
demand for this but I should be cautious
of the fact that this could
decline pretty soon um seeing that there
are more buyers um in the monthly time
frame than there is at a shorter time
frame and same thing with the quarter
time frame um so why don't we go ahead
and check to see what the margin is for
this item
and that was and that was okay that was
that
leaf grimy irit Leaf so again we're
going to go ahead and increase this
really
high and then we're going to go ahead
and decrease this really low to see what
it instantly sells
for okay and then we're going to see
okay so there is a pretty significant
Gap and you know that's kind of a point
proven where you guys should really look
at the picture the overall picture you
know this was pretty erratic throughout
um any time frame that I was looking at
um they has its bumps and Rises so this
might be something that I would flip so
right now um I'm going to go ahead and
invest in this right now and so it's
showing me so the what you sold it for
is what you're going to want to buy this
item for so I'm going to go ahead and
type into the chat 13
55 and then the bot price is going to be
its cap well its current cap which can
change literally in seconds so I'm going
to put
1421 I'm going to go ahead and the grand
exchange and put an offer for this and
then hopefully we can get this to sell
and buy by the time this video ends um
but this isn't really going to be a
video that I'm going to try and um do an
hour long uh flipping um video in um if
you guys want to see something like that
you know leave a comment down below if
but I'm going to go ahead and type in
1361 so it's just a little bit above
what I um was able to sell this for at a
very very low cost um and you're going
to want to put something like somewhere
in the middle some kind of random number
you know it could be 1362 1363 you know
whatever um just something random I'm
going to go ahead and
buy
um let's yeah let's go ahead and buy of
these so that's 1362 million and maybe
it'll buy maybe it won't um let's go
ahead and go to the high volumes tool
again okay so now the Raging potion the
Raging potion again is showing that
there is a significant amount of people
selling this as opposed to buying it and
the buy sell ratio indicates that so
this margin right here would be
something that I would be skeptical of
and if I click on this real quick
let's go ahead and review this real
quick
okay it's pretty erratic
um so that would be something that the
margins could possibly be there even
though there is more sellers than there
is buyers this is indicating that you
know it is kind of erratic and those
margins might actually be there for some
of you Merchants out there I'm not
saying that you should flip this I never
want to say you know flip a certain item
all I want to do is teach you guys how
to look at this so looking at the
monthly time frame I can see that it's
going up to
2.4k and all the way down to
1.9k and then looking at the weekly time
frame
2.1 2.5 so this would be something I
would flip and I would be looking at
this chart very carefully to make sure
that I'm picking a price point that I
know I can recover from so I wouldn't
really go for a price really like 2.2k I
would really go for something on a lower
end and right now it's showing me that
this is selling for pretty high based on
what you know I can get it for so why
don't we go ahead and check what the
margin on this is in game
currently I think it was the four dose
potion let's double check it's the three
dose okay that's what we always
check okay so it's three
dose okay let's quickly increas this
price see what it would sell for and um
you shouldn't do this when I'm when I'm
checking margins in game I want to
stress the fact that you shouldn't be
doing this for all types of items uh
this is really a safe bet for high
volume items because generally you're
not going to lose a lot of money um you
might lose like a thousand if you get
unlucky but that's insignificant loss so
it's nothing really to stress over but
you wouldn't do something um like this
for maybe like an armadel godsword or
peroria boots um this is really just for
high volume items and as we can tell
that uh there's a pretty significant Gap
here but I would be skeptical of paying
this price because earlier um while I
got cut off earlier I bought a herb a
different herb that was hitting its peak
and then I paid too much you know i'
paid something like this and then it
instantly crashed to about uh like a 400
GP loss and I had to wait I had to wait
a while on that to recover my losses um
so instantly I would be cautious of this
and I might not invest in this if I were
to um want to flip this and if I were to
invest in this again I would pick
something on the lower end um so I might
not get this in this video but I can see
that I can get this at around you know
close to 2K 2.1
k something something along those lines
so I'm going to go ahead and
invest um I'm going to go ahead and
invest something pretty low and it's
certainly not going to sell during this
video this is just going to be something
that's more longterm uh this is
something that I'm more comfortable with
so what was the margin I forgot to type
the margin let's go back real
quickly okay so it's
[Music]
2558 2558 and then
2770 and then it was able to buy
for that amount
okay so ranging potion three dose now
I'm going to put it for I don't know um
20 89 something random and that's kind
of the point you want to put something
random that isn't really um an even
number I'm just going to buy 500 of
these and that's kind of a significant
amount of my cash stack here um but this
again this is something that I'm
comfortable with um this would be
something for more of you experienced
Merchants out there you know I kind of
threw this in there uh for you guys but
for those of you guys who are new brand
new to flipping who have never done this
before um I wouldn't advise doing
something like that but there there's an
example um just in case you guys wanted
to be a little bit more risky um but
don't get mad at me if you guys lose
some money on that again that's kind of
a riskier investment that I just made um
so let's just click on this again and
then a dragon Dart okay so looks like
there's more people buying this than
there selling it and this is
um showing a a decent profit and earlier
um I saw you guys talking in chat where
um this was having a 300 GP margin and
again I'm not going to go um repeat
myself but you're going to want to look
at the entire picture as a whole to see
um is it really going to experience a
300 to 400 GP margin and if it does was
it kind of like an abnormality or was it
kind of something that happens all the
time and it really pushed that margin um
because it was something of a recent
crash or recent rise in that Price's um
price so if you look at this here uh
let's actually start with the yearly
view to see what it looks like Okay so
it was normally selling for a lot higher
and it's gone it's went down to
1.3k up to
2K let's look at the
quarterly okay looks pretty
flatlined okay flatlined
again okay wait let's go back to the
monthly view so you see this drop here
um this is why I always stress to look
at the graphs always always look at the
graphs if you see this table
showing uh like a 300 GP margin like I
saw earlier this morning or yesterday
morning is when I saw you guys talking
in chat about
this always look at the chart to see if
there was some abnormality that might
have skewed the table a little bit so
this right here 1.1k would have
obviously scooted the table it would
have obviously indicated that there was
a massive profit to make when it clearly
isn't true um so always look at the
graphs guys always always look at the
graphs and if you look at a shorter time
frame um it looks like those type of
bumps can happen on occasion but not
that
drastic
um okay
so looks like normally we're going to
experience a
50gp profit but this is something that's
pretty flatlined um looking at this
picture as a whole um it looks like the
profit margin here that it's showing is
really abnormalities you know these AB
normalities that I'm seeing here um so
this is actually an item that I wouldn't
flip unless I wanted to flip it in a
rather quick succession so maybe I can
flip this really quickly for you guys to
see um just an example of that so again
we're going to just going to increase
this really
quickly and then we're going to drop
low and let's see let's actually see if
we can experience an abnormality right
now by selling this for 1
GP nope okay we didn't get something
crazy and and we're seeing about a 100
GP margin so I'm going to see if I can
quickly flip this for you guys in the
video before I end this because I know
it's getting quite long
now okay so we have it at
2085 Dragon
Dart okay so let's do 20 93 something
something like that and I'm only going
to buy 100 of these cuz I only want to
give you guys an example this is
something that's pretty flatlined um I'm
not quite sure this is going to sell by
the time the end this video starts or
ends uh but we'll put that in there just
in
case and then if you look back at the
high volumes
tool okay and Tow flag potion there's a
whole lot more people selling this than
n is buying it uh so I don't think I
want to I don't even think I want to
look at this there's pretty much no one
buying this so I'm instantly going to
just not look at that but if we look
down at the dwarf weed
potion it looked like there was more
people buying this and they're selling
it with the buy sell ratio
positive um but if we look at this graph
here um okay so it looks like it looks
like it's um gone up and down on
occasion and our Dragon darts just sold
so let's just quickly try and sell
this as an example for you guys
actually wait what was the what was the
price okay so
2180 G oh buddy showing 2146 so that's
like so always Budd showing like a happy
medium between the two um so why don't
we put
35 so that'll be that'll be a a decent
profit if I were to buy a lot more of
these I only bought 100 of these as an
example um just to show you guys how
this works so that's something I put so
285 20
okay okay and I'm looking at the
quarterly
graph nothing thing to see okay so
recently it's been
declining was this something that was a
result of an
update maybe
um okay the margin looks pretty
significant let's see I'm trying to see
when winter do was released because
winter knut had a pretty significant
impact
on her prices in general and it doesn't
look
like it was something that impacted that
okay
H okay okay all right so looking at the
day
price um we're
gonna we're gonna see a pretty
significant Gap here um and if we look
down at the okay so our Dragon Dart is
show um so there you go guys there's an
example of how you would flip items
using this tool on a quicker succession
um seeing how the dragon darts had a
more Flatline graph this is something
that I could do while sitting at the GE
um so I could flip that there uh I think
I only made yeah I only made like a
couple thousand GP off of that I could I
could have invested more for the video
um but that's just an example for you
guys and looking at this um we're going
to see a pretty significant Gap but if
we look at the prices it's not that
significant actually it just means that
the trading volume isn't that high so
yeah we're seeing like
27 um 353
one like okay so obviously when we look
at the trading volume it's going to give
us a better picture as to why this is
happening so obviously um at certain
points in time there was no one buying
or selling
this um so that would indicate that um
that that would be the reason as to why
this is happening there's missing data
points at certain points in time so
there's a period of time where there
were no buyers here and if we look down
here there's a period of time that there
were no buyers and um it looks like
there were some spikes in buyers and
there's people who had sell offers so
maybe this is this was a a group of
people who have tried to invest in this
item and they're trying to get it off
their hands and it's just taking them
quite a long time to do so um so if I
were to flip
this um I would this would be something
that would be more long-term again I
probably wouldn't be able to flip this
within the video span um so why don't we
try checking the margins on this to see
where it plays okay so dwarf
weed so dwarf
weed increase the price
significantly and then drop it
down
okay so the profit is about what the
price was showing on the graph and as
well as the tool
so we're going to type in this
here
2080 okay and let's go ahead and try and
buy
these and see if we can get these in
time for the video to finish because I'm
going to wrap this up um this video is
already quite long and I'm sorry I'm
sorry guys I'm trying to trying to make
this as quickly as possible but as well
as trying to be as informative and
detailed with some examples as I can um
because I know I've seen a lot of
YouTubers and especially the guys that
we um post on our video guide section um
they've done some videos on this as well
where they sit at the GE for an hour and
try and flip videos um and they don't
really talk in detail as to you know
what to look for um which isn't a bad
thing you know I you know their videos
are really good and I really suggest you
guys check them out I'm just trying to
do a different approach on this so you
guys can see how I would think and how I
would approach this so I'm going to type
in 1989 and I'm going to buy uh let's
buy let's let's buy 500 of these and um
I guess I'll just leave the rest of this
cash T here or maybe I'll just maybe
I'll do another item we'll do one last
item before this video
finishes I know I keep saying I want to
finish this video quite soon but let's
do one
more okay Dragon ja Javelin heads let's
check this out
out and in this one right here it
actually shows the GE limit so on all
the tools um and all the pages for the
specific items you're going to see a g
GE limit um in which um you might see an
infinity sign and if you see an infinity
sign it doesn't mean Infinity it just
means we don't have the G known GE limit
for it yet and we're working on a
feature where um we're going to try and
fix it up later and Patch it up but um
so this is a good indication of how much
you could possibly buy um so that's
something a good look
at um just make sure we don't log
out
okay this was
um this
item
looks kind of
funky so it looks like it
crashed um and this would be thinking
back as to the light ballista and heavy
ballista because this would be something
that this would be used
for um the heavy ballista and light
ballista have really seen a really heavy
loss is on their I guess not a heavy
loss but just a big decline in their
value I remember when this thing first
came out people were trying to sell it
for like 40 million and now it's down to
1.2 million and if we look at the light
ballista light
ballista we're going to see that um
around 1.2 million that it's actively
trading at um so that's that's another
way to view these these items here is to
really get the whole picture of this um
we know that Dragon Javelin heads are
used for the ballistas and it's mainly
used for um I guess you could use it for
Zora I tried it out myself a little bit
of times um but it's mainly used for PVP
pkers but generally they're going to use
like Galls or gods hords or whatever
like that and especially since they um
nerfed The Heavy bista in which pures
can't use it anymore uh they're probably
going to switch to something else like
maybe um uh the granite mall or
something like that so I don't expect
this item to really have an increase in
price anytime soon this is an item that
I would expect to continuously
decline um it
might if we look here yeah I mean it
increased for quite some time uh maybe
due to the uh the dev mobs trying to you
know make some uh use out of this item
or the ballistas and then after people
you know didn't want to use the
ballistas anymore we can see that it
started to decline so um that's not
going to be an item that I want to flip
not going to want to invest in that
because I can expect this to
continuously Decline and not be really
that much of use and this is going to be
an ad Advanced concept here um really
for you Advanced Merchant out there if
you wanted
to um started stockpiling on items like
this that have no value
whatsoever and uh you you anticipate
that maybe the the jods want to make the
biss this relevant again to the point
where they're not 1.2 million you know
to the point where they're maybe like
three or 5 million 10 million to where
PES are actively using them again then
maybe the dragon Javelin heads would
increase in price again so um as an
advanced Merchant out there if you're
still watching this video uh those type
of merchants would start to stockpile on
this item quite heavily but not to the
point where they're in increasing the
price uh this would be something that
they're just kind of hoarding slowly
over
time and um you know just kind of
waiting for that moment that um these
items become relevant again but in the
meantime I don't really see this
becoming relevant and I think it's kind
of like a dead item but um you know
don't take my word on that if you're an
advanced Merchant out there and if
you're a new Merchant don't dig my word
on that don't invest in that um just
because I you know I talked about maybe
it becoming relevant again it's just a
concept just an idea um just trying to
throw at ideas on how I would think as a
merchant myself um so if we look down
here let's go
to H
I might just okay the sadom and Brew we
might just invest the rest of this into
sadom and Brew because they're quite
pricey for my cash
stack and um they did see a pretty
significant price lately because of
raids um people have been stocking up on
you know potions and stuff like that
thinking that you know they would be
quite of some use during raids um which
is something that you would um you
wouldn't assume in in a negative fashion
um you would think that this is
something that would be used because if
you die in raids then the your loot
reward gets dropped down so the idea is
to stay alive as as um as long as
possible so obviously these items have
increased in price but if we click on
the day price we're going to see um it's
had some pretty it's had some pretty big
gaps um not going to look at something
like this
because those are pretty
abnormalities and it looks like it's
been
declining quite a bit lately so it might
have hit its cap you know people might
not want to pay as much as they want to
even though there's still more
buyers so I'm going to if I find a
margin that's you know something like
this I'm not going to put a Buy offer
for that but let's see what we would
get okay siden Brew
oops we go it was the four dose I
believe yes it was increase this just a
little bit that's actually quite a lot
and then drop the price
down okay
7K okay so we're seeing almost almost a
200 GP profit um but I wouldn't Bank on
the 200 GP if we look down here um it
looks like it was selling for a lot
lower on the weekly time frame if we
look at the day time frame looks like it
was selling a lot lower as well so um
just because I saw um that there's a
200gp margin on this I'm going to aim
rather low uh this is something I'm
going to aim for like maybe maybe
something like that you know that would
be a decent price I think for me to
invest in
so let's see we'll type P Sarah
doen and then let's see it was down to
69 we'll do we do
6917 so put this in for 6917 and there
is definitely no way that I'm going to
expect this to sell by the time this
video finishes I'm just going to go
ahead and put the rest of this rest of
my cash deck into this uh let's go a
little bit lower
okay 230 and then um as a as a merchant
myself um I don't like to stand at the
Grand exchange so as you can tell out of
all the items that I picked well the
four five items that I picked only one
of them was able to sell in a rather
quick fashion and that was the one that
was a more flatlined graph so if you
wanted to flip items in a quicker
succession then you're going to want to
look for those Flatline graphs and that
might be something like um if you click
on the approximate profit and you go to
the lowest let's go let's not make a
negative profit then you would want to
find items that
have oh yeah okay um yeah you're going
to want to find items like this really
like consumables something that you um
that's always flowing through so you can
see that the the training volume is
really high um
so uh you can you can tell that this is
always flowing through
circulation um and um so why don't we do
why don't we pick an item real quick uh
a law ruin um and with these if you look
at you can obviously tell that it was
showing that profit margin being really
low um but if you wanted to flip really
quickly and you just wanted to get a
feel for how flipping feels um just so
you can get your feet wet then this
would be something that you would do
just to get used to it and we can tell
that the margin is really small so then
I would just put in a margin
for let's put it in for
197 and then we'll just put I don't even
think I can buy a lot of
these we'll put the rest of it yeah
we'll just put there the rest of our
cash attack into that and that would be
something that would flip rather quickly
and um oops didn't mean to click on
veric um um but if you wanted to flip at
the Grand exchange and your items
weren't flipping as quickly as you
wanted to then I suggest that you guys
do something else so right now I've been
actually fishing so while waiting for my
items to flip I go and do something else
and then when they are done flipping
then I come back and then I you know do
that whole process all over
again okay so um this video has been
quite long already I didn't really mean
for it to be this long guys I'm really
sorry sorry um but you know that's a
really pretty much in-depth guide on the
basics to merching and how you would
approach this from a more um experienced
Merchant um I'm not going to claim
myself to be an expert by any means all
I'm going to claim to be is just someone
who has been doing this for quite some
time and it's I'm pretty um comfortable
with making some of those Investments
that I showed earlier so if you guys
want to see um me doing like an hour
long flipping video of me trying to flip
these as quickly as possible you know
leave a comment down below you know let
me know that you guys want to see that
or if you guys have any suggestions on
any other type of videos you guys want
to see you know leave a comment Down
Below on that um so yeah guys um uh uh
so that's the end of the video and um
thank you guys so much for watching and
um you know till next time guys and good
luck merching
oh
[Music]